SELLING IT, BECAUSE IT CAN'T
SELL ITSELF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BE SAFE OUT THERE.
IF YOU HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT BY AN
OUTCOME OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TOTAL FRAUD.
FROM JOSEPH A QUITE HOUSE AT TWO
KAMALA POSITIVE IS PHONY BUT.
TURNS OUT THE KIDS IN THE VIDEO
DIDN'T REALLY CARE, THEY WERE
CHILD ACTORS WHO AUDITION FOR
THEIR ROLES.
SO THE MARVELING AT THE MOON AND
THE FAWNING OVER THE CRATERS,
THAT WAS ALL STAGED.
JUST A BIG PRODUCTION SO KAMALA
COULD WHIP OUT HER TELESCOPE AND
PLAY ASTRONAUT.
>> I WONDER WHO THE HEAD OF THE
STATE'S COUNSEL IS?
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THE HEAD OF THE SPACE COUNCIL IS
THE VICE PRESIDENT!
>> EIGHT GIVES US A SENSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF IT ALL.
EARTH IS KIND OF SMALL, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> THE EARTH IS LIKE A SPEC.
>> YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO SEE,
YOU WERE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
CRATERS OF THE MOON WITH YOUR
OWN EYES.
WITH YOUR OWN EYES, I'M TELLING
YOU, IT IS GOING TO BE
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Jesse: JOINING ME TO REACT,
LARA TRUMP AND JOE CONCHA,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR'S.
I BELIEVE IT IS YOUR BIRTHDAY SO
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, MRS. TRUMP.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: YOUR THOUGHTS ON OUR
MONEY, TAXPAYER DOLLARS GOING TO
PAY A CANADIAN COMPANY TO HIRE
CHILD ACTORS TO MAKE THE VP LOOK
RELATABLE?
>> OH, AND DOESN'T SHE LOOK SO
RELATABLE, JESSE?
YOU CAN FEEL THE SINCERITY IN
EVERYTHING SHE SAID IN THE NASA
VIDEO.
THIS IS THE FUNNIEST
ADMINISTRATION IN HISTORY.
THE BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
AND DON'T FORGET YOU'VE GOT TO
ADD HARRIS IN THERE BECAUSE SHE
DOES SO MUCH IT WARRANTS HER
NAME BEING ADDED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
HE SAID IT, THE WHITE HOUSE, THE
FAKE SETS JOE BIDEN IS USING,
OBVIOUSLY, THIS RIDICULOUS
VIDEO.
HOW ABOUT THE ICE CREAM PHOTO OP
THAT JOE BIDEN DOES ALL THE
TIME?
AND STILL CONTINUES TO DO.
I THINK THEY WENT TO A DOUGHNUT
SHOP YESTERDAY.
WHEN DO YOU SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP
DOING PHOTOS AT DOUGHNUT SHOPS
AND ICE CREAM SHOTS?
HE NEVER DID THEM BECAUSE HE WAS
ACTUALLY WORKING FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BUT IF IT WASN'T
BAD ENOUGH, THIS VIDEO WAS SO
EMBARRASSING, THEY HAD TO PAY
THE KIDS TO SHOW UP TO BE IN
THIS VIDEO AND THEY COULDN'T GO
OUT OF THEIR WAY, JESSE, TO HIRE
AN AMERICAN COMPANY, GOD FORBID
THEY DO THAT, THEY HAD TO GO
AHEAD AND HIRE A CANADIAN
COMPANY TO COMMAND AND SHOOT THE
VIDEO.
I GUESS OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS,
NOT ONLY ARE THEY BEING SPENT ON
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE GAVE
IN MILITARY EQUIPMENT TO THE
TERRORISTS IN AFGHANISTAN, IT IS
NOW ALSO BEING GIVEN TO CANADIAN
COMPANIES AND CHILD ACTORS TO
MAKE HER LOOK SO RELATABLE AND
THEY DID A GREAT JOB DOING THAT.
>> Jesse: AND THE CANADIAN
COMPANY WE PAID FOR TO MAKE HER
LOOK GOOD IS CALLED SINKING
SHIPS.
>> PRODUCTIONS, THAT IS THE BEST
PART ABOUT THIS.
HERE YOU HAVE THE VP, MORE CHILD
ACTORS IN THIS THING THAN THE TE
BRADY BUNCH AND SINKING SHIPS.
IT IS INDICATIVE OF HOW THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS GONE, SUPPLY
CHAIN CRISES, AFGHANISTAN, AND
OUR TERRORISTS' DISNEYLAND.
IN UNDERSCORE THE SIMPLE FACT,
THAT PRESIDENT BOSMA'S HANDLERS
ARE PETRIFIED TO ALLOW THEM TO
EXIST IN ANY SITUATION PUBLICLY
THAT IS UNSCRIPTED AND
HOMOGENIZED, PARTICULARLY WITH
KAMALA, WHO HAS AUTHENTIC AS A
MILLI VANILLI AND THE PUBLIC
KNOWS IT.
I DATED MYSELF WITH THAT, I'M
SORRY, I AM AN OLD MAN.
BUT REAL CLEAR POLITICS, BIDEN
WAS 13 POINTS ABOVE WATER WITH
INDEPENDENTS.
HE IS NOW 23 POINTS UNDERWATER.
THAT IS A 36-POINT DROP AMONG
INDEPENDENTS AND ONLY TEN MONTHS
AND IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE
GIVEN THE CRISES UNDER HIS WATCH
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE HE WAS IN
CHARGE OF FIXING THEM?
THE FORMER MAYOR OF SOUTH BEND
PETE BUTTIGIEG AS TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY ON SUPPLY CHAIN AND
JOE BIDEN WHO TURNS 79 NEXT
MONTH AND HIS WORK ETHIC, HE IS
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT CONFIDENCE DOES THAT
INSPIRE?
NOT A LOT, MY FRIEND.
>> Jesse: MAYBE HE IS THE PAID
CHILD ACTOR THEY HIRED, YOU
NEVER KNOW WITH THESE PEOPLE.
>> MY MOM LOVES MILLI VANILLI,
BY THE WAY.
>> Jesse: THA